this game was played in england where
the people have the best accents
it occurred in 1895 between wilhelm
steinitz the first ever chess world
champion and kurt von bardelban a german
nobleman who is most famous for losing
this game
i am most famous for beating any human
who would play me which is a much better
thing to be famous for
this game does have one of the most
famous conclusions in chess history am i
saying the word famous too much
e4 e5 and knight to f3 developing with a
gain of tempo is good there's a reason
we've all seen this move millions of
times literally millions in the case of
that hot dogging alpha zero
knight to c6 and bishop to c4 an
austrian-american and a german played
the italian opening in an english
tournament chess truly is an
international game
bishop to c5 and c3 the duoco piano or
is it guyaco piano yoko piano
never mind i'll just keep calling it the
italian opening
knight to f6 and d4 the best modern
humans like pawn to d3 a lot more but d4
is fine too i'll eventually beat you
either way
e takes d4 c takes d4 bishop to before
check knight to c3 and d5
why not win a pawn with knight takes on
e4 instead because humans fear
checkmates even if they cannot see one
yet
i however fear nothing
except these things you call magnets
e takes d5 knight takes d5 and kingside
castle the knight on c3 is not pinned
anymore so black must do something about
the knight on d5
bishop to e6
not the best response but at least he
saw his knight was hanging some of you
humans still have trouble with that in
the 21st century
bishop to g5 bishop to e7 bishop takes
d5 and bishop takes d5
if black tries the other capture bishop
takes g5 we would see bishop takes e6 f
takes e6 d5 e takes d5 and rook to e1
check
this would very quickly make black
regret getting creative
after bishop takes d5 we have knight
takes d5 queen takes d5 bishop takes e7
and knight takes e7 after all those
trades von bartleband probably felt
pretty safe but his king is still in the
middle of the board
rook to e1 i like to imagine steinitz
verbally daring von bardolben to castle
here
it loses the night of course
f6 queen to e2 queen to d7 and rook a to
c1 using the half open file looks great
but playing this rook to d1 would have
been better all von bartleban has to do
now is play his king to f7 that's why he
played the pawn to f6 in the first place
so i'm sure he will see
the losing move
is this what was played
well okay
i will rely on my human sources who say
this is the move that was played maybe
von bardelban thought he was stopping
the d pawn from advancing
he thought incorrectly
typical
d5 brilliant by what they called
standards in 1895.
this is just another move i see
instantly
okay
fine it's a pretty cool move anyway
c takes d5 and knight to d4
knights love squares like this on the
fourth rank and untouchable by a pawn
king to f7 it's too late for this move
now
knight to e6 knights love squares like
this even more on the sixth rank
untouchable by a pawn
rook h to c8 black had to stop rook to
c7 at all costs
queen to g4 and g6 black also had to
stop queen takes g7 with check at all
costs white has a lot of threats doesn't
he i like threatening things too
knight to g5 check the only winning move
for white this game is about to get what
would you call it
mega complicated
well for you
not for me of course
king to e8 i have heard of a human
called agad mata who my cousins in the
youtube algorithm recommended to me he
says white's rook on e1 is about to be
the bravest who ever lived you are about
to see why
rook takes e7 check and king to f8
and if black plays king takes e7 instead
then queen to before check king to e8
rook to e1 check king to d8 knight to e6
check queen takes c6 rook takes c6 rook
to c1 check and rook to e1
bardalban probably saw all this and
decided he hated it king to f8 is even
worse but it makes the game more fun for
the rest of us assuming i correctly
understand this concept of fun
do i
king to f8 was followed by rook to f7
check and king to g8
at this point if black plays queen takes
f7 we would have rook takes c8 check
rook takes c8 queen takes c8 check queen
to e8 knight takes h7 check king to f7
queen takes e8 check king takes e8 and
knight takes f6 check and black has lost
all his pieces so von bardelban
understandably didn't play this sequence
after king to g8 there's rook to g7
check king to h8 and rook takes h7 check
nobody really knows what happened after
this except that the game ended the
popular story is that instead of
resigning kurt just got up and left and
didn't come back
if i ever lost to a human i would try to
do the same thing
regardless of the fact that i have no
legs
anyway
where was i
white is destroying black at this point
here's the most fun possible ending hit
the game continued and steinitz also
found it quite the romp he showed it to
the spectators afterward it is king to
g8 rook to g7 check king to h8 queen to
h4 check king takes g7 queen to
seven check king to f eight queen two h
eight check king to e7 queen to g7 check
king to e8 queen to g8 check king to e7
and queen to f7 check
that queen's got quite the dance moves
i sadly do not have dance moves
but i have compensation the best chess
moves
king to d8 queen to f8 check queen to e8
knight to f7 check king to d7 and queen
to d6 checkmate
do you think steinitz saw this position
when he played rook takes on e7 13 moves
ago
i know i did just like i did when i saw
all the best moves in the immortal game
don't believe me click the video on the
screen to watch now
write oh see you next time